OF MICHAEL COHEN.
WE'LL GIVE YOU DETAILS OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
THEN YOU'LL HEAR FROM SEAN
HIMSELF AHEAD.
FIRST TONIGHT, THE FULL
TRANSCRIPT OF FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY'S INTERVIEW
WITH GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS HAS
BEEN RELEASED.
IT'S A MASSIVE INTERVIEW
CLOCKING IN AT MORE THAN FIVE
HOURS.
IT'S DEEPLY REVEALING.
BY NOW YOU HEARD ABOUT WHAT
COMEY HAS HAD TO SAY ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP AND NOT VERY MUCH
OF THAT WAS NEWSWORTHY IT TURNED
OUT.
THE REAL VALUE OF THIS INTERVIEW
IS WHAT IT SAYS ABOUT JAMES
COMEY.
BY THE END YOU REALIZE THAT
CONEY NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN FBI
DIRECTOR.
HE'S TOO PARTISAN.
TRUMP'S MAIN MISTAKE WAS NOT
FIRING HIM ON INAUGURATION DAY.
COMEY DEFENDS HIS PROSECUTION OF
MORE THAT STEWART WHO WENT TO
JAIL FOR LYING TO PROSECUTORS.
HE ATTACKS GENERAL PETRAEUS.
ACCORDING TO COMEY, HE SHOULD
HAVE FACED MORE CHARGES FOR
MISHANDLING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
HE SHOULD HAVE GONE TO PRISON
FOR LYING.
IN HIS WORDS "LYING STRIKES AT
THE HEART OF OUR RULE OF LAW IN
THIS COUNTRY."
FAIR ENOUGH.
BUT THEN COMEY GOES ON TO TALK
ABOUT THE MARC RICH CASE.
YOU REMEMBER THAT.
ON HIS WAY OUT OF OFFICE, BILL
CLINTON SOLD A PRESIDENTIAL
PARDON TO A WANTED FELON WHO
FLED THE COUNTY.
COMEY SAYS "I NEVER HEARD OF
ANOTHER FUGITIVE FROM JUSTICE
WAS PARDONED."
SO GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS ASKS
THE QUESTIONS, DID YOU DRAW ANY
CONCLUSIONS ABOUT THE CLINTONS
FROM THOSE EXPERIENCES?
COMEY SAYS NO, NONE AT ALL.
SELLING A PRESIDENTIAL PARDON TO
A FUGITIVE SAYS NOTHING ABOUT
THE CLINTONS OF THEIR CHARACTER.
AND THEN HE SAYS CLINTON IS HARD
WORKING.
LORETTA LYNCH GETS THE SAME SOFT
TREATMENT.
HE CONCEDES HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL
CALLED THE INVESTIGATION OF
HILLARY CLINTON AS A MATTER.
>> HIS FIRST CONCERN WHEN SHE
TOLD HIM TO REFER TO THE CLINTON
E-MAIL CONTROVERSY AS A MATTER
RATHER THAN AN INVESTIGATION.
DID YOU THINK SHE WAS DOING THAT
TO PROTECT HILLARY CLINTON?
>> I DIDN'T KNOW.
IT WORRIED ME.
GAVE ME AN UNCOMFORTABLE
FEELING.
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN HAD BEEN
TRYING TO COME UP WITH OTHER
WORDS TO DESCRIBE IT.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW, I DON'T
KNOW, SAYS JAMES COMEY.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO DRAW ANY
CONCLUSIONS FROM THAT.
HE HAS NO IDEA IF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WAS BEHAVING POLITICALLY
WHEN SHE TOLD HIM TO PARROT THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN'S TALKING
POINTS.
HE GOES ON TO SAY THAT LORETTA
LYNCH IS A SMART PERSON THAT HE
RESPECTS VERY MUCH.
IN THIS MIDDLE OF THIS SAGA,
PRESIDENT OBAMA REPEATEDLY
DISMISSED THE ENTIRE HILLARY
CLINTON E-MAIL INVESTIGATION AS
A NOTHING BURGER.
OF COURSE HILLARY DID NOTHING
WRONG, OBAMA SAID.
COMEY CONCEDES THAT OBAMA IS A
VERY SMART LAWYER AND HE SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN BETTER TO WEIGH-IN ON
AN ACTIVE INVESTIGATION AS
PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULDN'T DO THAT.
"DO YOU THINK OBAMA WAS TRYING
TO COLOR THE CASE, GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS ASKED.
COMEY REPLAYS, "I DON'T KNOW, I
DON'T THINK SO."
THERE'S A THEME HERE.
AGAIN AND AGAIN, PARTISAN
DEMOCRATS GET EVERY BENEFIT OF
EVERY DOUBT FROM JAMES COMEY.
HE CAN'T RUSH TO CONCLUSIONS
UNTIL HE SEES THE WHITE CIRCLES
UNDER DONALD TRUMP'S EYES THAT
HE'S HAPPY TO SPECULATE.
COMEY SAYS THAT LYING IS WHAT
BOTHERS HIM MOST.
HE'S DEVOTED HIS LIFE TO
FIGHTING DISHONESTY.
THAT'S WHY HE WROTE THE BOOK, HE
SAYS.
BUT HE SAYS THAT JAMES CLAPPER
IS THE PUBLIC SERVANT THAT HE
ADMIRES THE MOST.
THE SAME JAMES CLAPPER THAT LIED
TO CONGRESS, FALSELY CLAIMING